Let's consider the
following problem.
Suppose we have
an inclined plane.
And on this inclined
plane, we have a block.
And down here at the bottom
of the inclined plane
is a little bumper.
It can be a spring of some type.
And what we have is the block
is sliding down the inclined
plane, bouncing off the
bumper, and sliding up
the inclined plane.
And what we'd like to do
is find the acceleration
of the block for both cases.
So when it's sliding down, let's
do an analysis on that motion.
Well, the first
thing we have to do
is, again, identify our system.
In this case, just the
block will be our system.
So we'll put in the
block as our system.
And now we have to analyze
the forces on the block
as it's sliding down.
There is a friction
with a coefficient mu k.
And so we have the
gravitational force, mg.
We have a normal
force of the surface
on the block pointing up.
And because the block
is sliding down,
remember that our friction
force is opposing that motion.
Now when you have a
free body force diagram,
we have to decide how should we
choose our coordinate systems.
What we want to
encourage you is not
to choose a coordinate
system, unit vectors,
horizontal and vertical,
just because that's the way
one always does it, but to use
the constraints of the system
to help you choose
the coordinate system.
Now a technique for doing
that is to draw what you think
will be the acceleration
on your sketch.
So I expect that a is going
to go down the inclined plane.
That's taking into
account that there
is no motion perpendicular
to the inclined plane.
Drawing the
acceleration-- remember,
acceleration is not a
force-- but this gives me
a clue for how I should
choose my unit vectors.
I'll choose them, so
that I have points down.
And so I essentially have
a one dimensional motion.
And I'll choose j
hat pointing out.
Now I'll introduce
an angle theta.
That's the same
angle theta here.
And one has to be a little
bit careful in doing
these types of sketches.
But this is also
the angle theta.
And now I've chosen a
coordinate system, unit vectors.
I've indicated relevant angles.
And the rest of
the problem is just
vector decomposition in
applying Newton's second law.
So we'll write
down F equals m a.
And I'm going to
indicate a d for we're
talking about the
acceleration downwards.
And we have two
directions to analyze,
the i hat and the
j hat directions.
So in the direction
tangent to the surface,
we have a gravitational force,
downward, mg sine theta.
We have the kinetic friction
force opposing that motion.
And that's equal to m a d,
where a d is the x component
of the acceleration.
In the vertical direction,
we have the normal force
minus m g cosine theta.
And here's where our choice
of coordinate system helps us.
The constraint of the
system is that a y
is 0 when we choose y to be
the perpendicular direction.
So this side is 0.
Now I look at this,
and I see a f and N.
And that's only two
equations and three unknowns.
But now I have a for slope
for my friction, which
is that the kinetic friction is
equal to a coefficient mu k N.
And I can see from this
equation, that's mu k mg cosine
theta.
And now I'm in position
in which to substitute
my friction into this equation
and solve for the acceleration.
Notice the mass will cancel.
And what I get is that the
acceleration going down
is just equal to g times
sine theta minus mu k
cosine of theta.
And so that's how we can
analyze the acceleration
when the block is sliding down.
Next, we want to
analyze the acceleration
when the block is going up.
Now when you have
a case like that,
it's sometimes easier,
again, just to draw.
We'll still choose N.
Now, the interesting
thing is, which way
is the acceleration pointing?
Just because the
block is going up,
the acceleration is
still pointing down.
How do you know that?
Well, we'll see that when
we analyze the forces.
So we still have N. We have mg.
But now, the crucial
point is-- this
is going up-- the
crucial point here
is that the kinetic friction
is always opposing the motion.
So when the block of sliding up,
the kinetic friction is down.
And all that we have
is a sign change here.
This is now plus.
If I choose my i hat and j
hat in the same direction,
notice both of these forces
have a positive component
in the i hat direction.
So the acceleration
will be down.
And rather than do all
the algebra, all I'm doing
is changing the sign.
And I get that a up is equal to
g sign theta plus mu k cosine
theta.
And although it may seem
slightly counter-intuitive
that the acceleration as the
block is going up in magnitude
is bigger than the acceleration
as the block is going down.
And that's because
of the direction
of the kinetic friction force.